Shawn in New Jersey take a couple of
phone calls the reason I called I having
some marital issues I guess and I think
well you've come to the right place if
you have marital issues I'm considered a
marriage advice expert so my wife and I
have been married maybe seven years now
we have two little beautiful children
the issue is that we've basically
stopped having sex well there's a
shocker
if you never heard of that before she
have the kids in the closet and get some
bill those in the mix
train you why you got time for a little
Ronnie advice sure hey Ron get in here
I'm coming home at 5:00 and that [ __ ]
better be in business yeah
what are you making this cuz you laugh
at guys like this you kind of like what
the [ __ ] [ __ ] what should he do seven
years yeah and it's done yeah what would
you do dude you ever like try setting up
some candles in the bedroom and you know
give her a nice massage yeah you know
and then Dan you work your way in there
you know what I'm saying okay what are
you saying
you get a roll naked go ahead put some
candles around the bed yeah light him up
right you know and then you you get the
KY massage oil go ahead give her a nice
massage you work you know work your way
down to her ass all right
you get you put your finger in her ass
you gotta work it really good like what
do you mean like you must suck give her
a nice back massage the whole thing on
the airstream sound the let down the
lace and you flip her over you do the
front all right did you flip it back
over again where you don't touch any
side up close but you don't touch yeah
does he say to her hey honey tonight I
want to do something special for you I
want to give you a message it don't say
it set it all up oh you do this I've
done it I can't see Ronnie setting up
candles oh yeah that he's a romantic hey
listen if you want to get laid man you
like [ __ ] candles I picture it I
spill over inner ass
I pictured like remember the TV show
Dexter the kill room Ronnie's got it all
set up she doesn't know if she's getting
beheaded or when did he become a lover
do you got a tire up yeah I think as a
married man with two kids oh okay there
you go yeah here's by the way Ronnie's
had kids he knows about this yeah he's
gonna save this guy's what do you know
what does that mean it just means you're
you you're not coming from a place where
you know what you're talking about what
he should turn her on to get her in the
mood is lightened her load around the
house helped out a rat that's what
happened once the kids come out he's got
a point there do some laundry do some
dishes and do the laundry then you're
[ __ ] your wife and you cook that's
why she wears my blow job thing you
gotta be good to her you gotta meet her
needs you I do the laundry and then say
hey Shirley said you're supposed to [ __ ]
me and then all of a sudden be sexual
they do have to be worked into it right
when you're dating it's an exhibition
game it's not being taken seriously the
minute kids come out nobody's keeping
stats if your wife sees you sitting down
with your feet up but Ronnie's got that
massage she's in mom mode you got to get
her out of mom when they're worried
about the kids are not ready to lay down
we have to be out of here Shawn does any
of this help you in other words you
gotta be a man and get things going dude
step up the game don't just wait for
something to happen do you text her
during the day at all or do you call her
like hey baby how are you and how's it
going how's your day do you do that no
you're a [ __ ] you got invest buddy you
got a call up and say
doing a dishes with my doc yeah
well Ronnie's right I mean she probably
thinks you're not interested exactly
yeah you don't feel her pain
Ronnie you wouldn't put up with that I
mean if you don't have sex for a week I
can't deal with that
no you got to have your sex right I
can't deal with that you serve a dinner
and you have a [ __ ] in a hot dog bun
[Applause]
[Music]
with a side of balls and some ash tweets
mustard